did you know that you could take your TV
from this to this honestly I was shocked
when I saw how much of a difference the
light me fantasy plus kit made in terms
of immersion both for watching videos
for watching movies and for playing
games now I've seen the Philips Hue sync
but it is expensive 500 bucks for just
the basics or over 900 to match our
partner light me's new flagship fantasy
plus kit that comes in at 299 bucks so
that is less than a third of the price
or you could actually get the essentials
bundle for just the TV kit and then be
able to add extra accessories later plus
you can get 10 off using our link down
below now to be honest I was a bit
skeptical at first you guys know that we
get thousands of companies that reach
out to us I turned most of them down and
I thought that this kit had to have some
major compromise sizes but when I looked
at the specs I saw that this new light
me supports 4K 60 1080 120 HDR Adobe
Vision just like the Philips Hue so we
agreed to check it out but I was still
hesitant to see how it would perform and
like I said it blew me away starting out
with watching videos this thing gives
you such an immersive experience right
here I have a 55 inch TV and I have it
set up on my office because right now
I'm still working on my basement man
cave where this TV will go later and
even though it's set up here and it's
not optimal the results are still
amazing it starts out with the sync box
that controls everything and the light
strip that goes on the back without any
cutting and then we have the two light
bars on the side that add extra fill now
I wish I could have these a little bit
further apart which you'd be able to in
your home and I'll be able to do that
later but even here the results look
awesome and these can actually be laid
flat I'll show you guys everything that
comes in the kit and how to set it up in
just a bit and then we have the light
strip at the top which you can actually
put below a couch behind a console table
whatever you want you can get an
extension kit and it's not obscenely
expensive like Hue is and that just
fills in the whole room and only when it
actually is needed based off of the
content and everything is controlled
with the app that is very easy to set up
and use or you can use Amazon Alexa
Google assistant or SmartThings along
with the desktop app now for movies
especially ones with action the results
are crazy the regular TV by itself looks
boring but with light me everything gets
filled in with matching colors and it
just gives you a whole nother experience
you guys know I have a big theater set
up in my basement this fills in the Holy
with color it kind of extends your
screen it's a little bit different than
that but it changes the ambience even to
what theater can't do and you just have
your normal TV now I was worried that
the light me wouldn't be able to keep up
it'd be a little bit janky something
like that but it worked great even
though it is just a sink box on its own
there's other options on the market but
they require this clunky camera with
this arm that sticks off of your TV at
all times and you have to put little
sticky pads to calibrate to be able to
do a good job well now there is a great
alternative now I don't just want to
focus on movies inside the app here we
have our video function we also have
Recreation which I was using for live
concerts for music videos and then we
have a gaming mode now if you're
somebody likes to turn on music and
music videos in the background just to
have a play have a visual uh this just
takes it up to a whole another level
especially for music videos that are
more colorful or when you have different
stuff going on or even just for a basic
thing because you have visuals that
expand much further than just your TV
and they also have this whole music tab
section where it will actually listen to
uh the audio if you're not playing
visuals and you can switch between
different modes for how fast you want it
to update and it will go off of that so
you don't have to be playing music
videos now where I think this was really
awesome is for gaming whether you're
playing an action or an adventure game
where you're walking around or maybe
driving a car or playing a first person
shooter my experience was great even
though I thought that it wouldn't be
that good I thought I would just want to
focus on the content I wouldn't want
anything distracting but it was actually
quite surprising now out of the box they
actually have this gaming mode that you
can select effect and then in that
gaming mode it is optimizing for playing
games now sometimes when things reach a
corner and they're quickly changing I
did notice that it was just flashing a
little bit too much but thankfully in
the app there's actually this diffusion
setting which will adjust how often
things change and how close they need to
be and how bright so I actually was able
to switch from the crazy very fast one
and that is great for things like rocket
League where there's a lot of stuff
going on down to a lower level where I
still get that nice immersive effect but
it is not distracting and that's easy to
do in the app so depending on your
preference and what kind of game you're
playing you can adjust that so you can
still enjoy the experience and it
doesn't really pull you out of it and
with that you can adjust the brightness
on the main kit as well as all of the
other lights individually along with
that we have this scene tab so you don't
have to have your t TV even on to be
able to set an ambience in your room and
now let me show you how easy it was to
set this up when I got it this is the
new lightning fantasy plus TV
backlighting kit it comes with three
different pieces now this is the main
kit right over here on this top card we
have the instructions as well as QR
codes for the app and inside we have our
user manual these sticky pads and the
hardware to install it along with an
HDMI cable that will give you full
performance now here is the actual
lightning Neo box this is the updated
version with HDMI 2.0 we have our power
adapter right over here and then
underneath is where we have our LED
strip that can support 16.7 million
colors and it has a USB type-c port
instead of a cheap micro and here are
the life bars I'm honestly impressed
with the build quality of these the
plastic feels nice you definitely are
getting your money is worth and then
underneath here we have these mounts if
you're going to be putting them
vertically along with all the other
necessary Hardware including multiple
mounts if you want to stick it to your
wall either flat or at an angle and high
quality 3M stickies and the third box is
the additional light strip that you also
get to kick up the lighting here we have
a tiny control box along with the other
hardware and the light strip itself now
as far as the actual installation it's
actually pretty easy to start off you
want to clean off the back of your TV so
there's no dust or anything so the
strips stick well and then unwind the
actual strip and there's different
sections one for each side I started out
with the bottom right hand side because
that's where my USBC cable is going to
be and then I just worked my way piece
by piece doing the top the left hand
side and then the bottom make sure you
press the strips down firmly so they
attach and then you have these little
plastic pieces with 3M tape that that's
going to hold down the corners and in my
case my TV has very slim bezels so
because of that I have extra slack in
the corner cable so I also use those
plastic holders to hold the cables down
and generally you want to hold down the
edge of the strip but if there's any
section that doesn't really grip well
you can put it there now I decided to
attach the sink box using the included
velcro to the back of my TV because the
shape is perfect for that and I attached
it right over here just to make sure I
don't have too much slack in that USB
type-c cable now mine is flipped upside
down because I want to wrap my cables
but that is up to you so there we have
it all of the light strips are attached
to the back of the TV they're nice and
tidy and everything is clean and
minimalistic you can go ahead and attach
the HDMI cable to your TV to the sync
box and then plug in the HDMI to
whatever you're using for example I am
using my Xbox now as far as the light
bars these are incredibly easy all you
do is literally plug them into the
splitter and then you plug them into the
power adapter and into the wall now this
full kit also has a long light strip
which you can attach to your ceiling
like we are doing or you could attach it
to the backs of your console or
underneath your couch this thing is very
long so we decided to put it right up to
the ceiling so that the light will
spread onto the wall and onto the
ceiling itself and that just plugs into
its mini sync box and then to the power
outlet and finally plug it in to see all
of those strips and bars come to light
and now that all of that is set up let's
go ahead and download the app just go to
app store or the Play Store and type in
light me and then you need to register
but the cool thing is you can actually
use Google or Apple to create an account
bam I love how instant that is we're
gonna allow for Bluetooth and let's
connect a new device I'm gonna put this
in my office hit plus and right away we
have four device is found it actually
pre-selected the Wi-Fi that I'm
connected to it connected to everything
I'm going to select office and here are
all of the accessories so with all that
said what is my conclusion with this kit
well it does its job way better than I
expected it is highly customizable it is
a lot less expensive than the Hue
without a crazy bar on top of it that I
can't imagine anybody would want to do
that and it's very minimalistic now with
actual box you only have one HDMI input
and one output and you do need to have
something to plug into it like I had my
Xbox plugged in or you could do
something else so if you just have a TV
there's no output on most TVs and with
that if you have multiple devices that
you want to connect to it there's just
that one input now you could solve this
with an inexpensive HDMI switcher if
you're not already using a receiver but
if you do have a home theater system
then you have multiple inputs going into
that so then it's not a problem so if
you're looking for something that's
going to give you more immersion
something that's going to set the set a
whole Ambience and give you something
that's very unique that most people
don't have it's a whole nother
experience and I would definitely
recommend it even this full-size kit is
much more affordable than the other
Alternatives like the Hue or you could
just get the basic kit if you want to
start out and then add on Extras when
you want to in the future go ahead and
check it out down below click that
Circle above to subscribe and check out
one of those great videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
foreign